i want to jump to the story um we often
criticize the great firewall of china
the manipulation they have on social
media and on the internet and the news
people can get access to like the
tiananmen square massacre like you can't
find out things about it
we have the story from timcast.com
twitter unveils crisis misinformation
policy content labeled false by the
platform will be hidden during
catastrophes or emergencies wow yeah you
know exactly where that's going
we've got all these videos coming out uh
out of ukraine one of them was i love
this news story it was like cessation of
hostilities in mariopol
and it's like what does that mean and
then you actually dig into it it's like
oh a surrender from the ukrainians and
victory for for the russians but they
don't want that to be the message that
ukraine is losing
this is what i feared with the the us
disinformation board the dhs
disinformation board that the goal was
to put out talking points like here's a
list of fake news then twitter could go
oh
we we're just we're just taking down
things that the government has said is
fake news so the government is working
through twitter to censor information
now that got shut down twitter seems to
be i don't know if that was that was
ever going to happen but twitter is
moving forward with censorship anyway
now
you're not going to know what's really
happening in the world yeah they're
they're they're
we are following the footsteps of
everything we claim to be against with
the great firewall of china
yeah that's why i fear the country i
love becoming the country left that's my
campaign slogan because everything i see
is like somebody wants to rule over us
and taking their tactics and terms and
strategies all straight from a communist
party's playbook who are those people
what do they want
what kind of country we want to live in
i'm i'm terrified
that you know i i don't know
i think when you look at the project
veritas expose you start to realize who
these people at twitter really are
the true believers the people
we had that one guy who said they want
to change the world you know they're
here for the mission or whatever
these are cult zealots this is this is
brainwashed psychotic cult behavior but
you know what those people don't realize
they will be thrown under the bus
they're the first out but people need to
understand
the one thing that we all understand is
that the people who foment revolution
are the first to be purged after the
revolution why because the people
running the new government know who
overthrew the last one they don't want
it to happen to them yeah i mean we
already seeing it happen
on a smaller scale at the social level i
mean people who were considered on the
left yesterday are being destroyed by
the left today the revolution eats its
own children that's always how it goes
that's why our kids are so important for
somebody
parents should be parents responsibility
if schools are not teaching that a real
history so we do not repeat you know
this kind of human tragedies you know
meanings meanings are going to die
already dead it's like
how come are we just repeating this
horrible horrible stories like i was
having like a ptsd last two years to see
what happened in our country because to
bring back all my horrible childhood
memories well let me ask you lily what
can we do in the united states to avoid
the fate that your country is
experiencing or the country which you
came from is experiencing i think we
have to
start to wake up ourselves
and once we wake up we need to keep our
family our friends our neighbors close
regardless political party regardless
who they are they might be very lefty
social justice warriors i want to go to
talk to them because when i have
face-to-face talk with people have
hopefully they allow me to tell my
stories have a several conversation like
we sit down here
maybe they will start wondering um
she has a credibility to tell her
personal story maybe i need to look at
different source information lots of
people don't know the truth because they
have been conditioned for years to
believe in their own source of
information you know it's like a they
have this virtual sickness they think
they're right they think like i got
demonized all the time to you know say
i'm an evil republican i'm a racist i i
cuddle to the white nationalists or
something all kind of name corny those
people even don't know me they even
don't know me
they hate my gun picture they think that
it's like why why are you doing this
that's so scary
i'm a five one okay asian woman what is
my leverage can i tell you guys can i
tell you something funny
so uh just to the to the left of where
just we're important we have an actual
model 1861 union civil war rifled musket
never been fired meant condition i'm a
fan of history and uh it's it's it's
it's the least dangerous it's not
legally a gun because you have to you
know muzzle load it like the old school
days
and we've had several guests on this
show who are liberal
they won't touch it
they're they're afraid yeah they're
terrified of it without saying who
exactly but i come in here and um
we have real guns and uh i can bring in
someone like thomas massey and he and
he's like oh yeah yeah wonderful great
and then we handle we have everything
safe everything's secured we have safes
and all that stuff for any any real
firearm but uh the libertarians the
conservatives are like they know how to
handle it they know how to be safe and
anybody we're not sure of we we have
like a dummy i always give people uh uh
something they can't actually fire give
them the rules and if they handle it
improperly they're cut off you can't
touch any guns anymore but these we have
up here
are our uh antiques
and when when i come in with with
somebody who's a libertarian or
conservative you know they'll pick it up
they know the rules they don't point at
anybody even though this thing is so far
from firing it's it's you know not out
of the question
and then when we have these liberal
guests i'm like do you want to you just
take a look at the union civil
i can't touch that
scared so that's a saying when i first
came to this country i never touched gun
in china
you do feel scared of guns for some
reason
because you just had no knowledge how to
use it how to train to use it properly
right
but
my husband you know from texas they took
me to shooting range and they showed me
how to you know and you know train a
little bit at the beginning i scare
everybody i just pick up guns like
opponent everybody's oh no no no no it's
like that's the first the wrong thing
you did it's like you pulled at people
i don't know i didn't know because i
just like oh what is this what is that
so they showed me they trained me and
when i first filed a shot i've it's like
it was like a shocking to me it's like i
actually feel very empowered
empowered i never had that feeling
because like i was just afraid of guns i
was afraid of guns we were conditioning
to believe that i think for me the power
was scary
like not like i was terrified of it but
i was just like the realization of how
much power what you actually had at that
moment that no one no one could say
anything to you and it's like you have
to be responsible yeah you have to
understand when you're when you're
holding that weapon
i think it's funny when people like joe
biden are like get a shotgun and i'm
like wow really
is this nobody let off three blasts i
was like what are you saying yeah fire
in the air whatever it's like first of
all
so
when uh when when we went to a range and
we had an instructor talking to us the
12 gauge was the one that actually
scared everybody you know the the five
five six people were the the you know
the ar-15 people were just like oh wow
you know i didn't expect that but the
12-gauge hurt
people's shoulders and it was like yeah
the shotgun is probably not the right
thing for a beginner but you get people
like joe biden and these liberals who
don't know anything about guns and
they're just like you get a shotgun
you're fired no no no don't do that
don't do that talk to an expert go to
you know if you go to the if you go to
your gun store or your firearms dealer
ask them for expertise and you
definitely want to get training because
i'm far from an expert but you know
there's a lot of things that i was
surprised by does he have a
misinformation all the time
oh yeah yeah yeah
it's like on tv
i want to correct something i said three
blasts let me read the full quote from
him just so you can we can answer that
question does just joe spread
misinformation often this is this was
him talking to his wife all right i said
jill if there's ever a problem just walk
out on the balcony here walk out on the
balcony here okay
walk out put the double barrel shotgun
and fire two blasts outside the house
what firstly firstly
i mean
without even considering how
unbelievably dangerous that is he said a
double barrel shotgun so waste all of
your ammo now you have to reload also no
do not aimlessly fire a gun outside of
your balcony he didn't say point it up
he said walk out put that double barrel
shotgun
and fire two blasts outside the house
what does that what does that mean it
means the man was slightly less declined
cognitively at this point because the
sentence structure works but what he's
saying is insane i like how he's like
you're double barrel it's like okay i
guess i think jill carries a double
barrel shotgun around but also why would
you
well he's an old guy it's like what is
his elmer fudd
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get a double
barrel for home defense
so what do you think about that what do
you think about elon musk say that
whoever controls his teleprompter is
controlling running this country it's
like what's that like it's funny because
it's halfway to the point of saying he's
puppeted but it's also he called him ron
burgundy that if whatever gets written
he says
and it's true people don't understand
this too one of the reasons joe biden
will stutter or or pause or ramble is
because the prompter prompters get stuck
you'll notice it with tucker carlson and
i maybe i'm wrong but you know having
worked with teleprompters tucker will
say things where he'll be like
now we're hearing that the government
wants to allow an illegal immigrants
it's wrong they shouldn't do that
actually and that last sentence is
nothing he's not saying anything
because the prompter's rolling and he
needs to say something as the next words
come up and so joe biden will just be
like
well
like in the quote he says he lives in
like a wooded and somewhat secluded area
before saying this but still very bad
advice like don't it's still
yeah fire off fire off what you got and
then yeah have nothing well i think i
think the middle term is coming i heard
have you heard that they lost like at
last 10 states who had a primary i heard
they were like a record turnout for the
republican primaries really yes and
matt kippy phrased the people told me
this morning said you know i think uh um
it's it's a message sending out to the
whole country and regardless what the
you know democrats are doing you know
they're trying to use the you know like
their base and you know they're still i
was told don't go walk to this supreme
court because there might be lots of
protests thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you